if you start a youtube channel and you
have two views that's embarrassing but
if you have 2 000
then that's cool i find our general
attitude towards being a beginner so
judgmental negative backwards
pressurizing and counterproductive that
i don't understand how we are even
supposed to start doing something
effectively or why there is just so much
friction in the way of getting started
with something new as an adult there are
so many people that i know that end up
quitting things very very early because
that upwards pressure becomes too much i
also know people who never even get
started which is in a way even sadder
with things because they are too
embarrassed to kind of
have other people know that they want to
try something new and in general it's
actually these sorts of people who on
top of the upwards pressure are their
own bigger buddies and have internalized
these sorts of thoughts of kind of
unworthiness and embarrassment for doing
things because it just will bring all
this judgment from people who know them
and it's actually quite funny because in
a way for example for a lot of these
people who let's say they want to start
a youtube channel if i could guarantee
that they would have 5 000 subscribers
from day one they would immediately
start it because all of that kind of
pressure would go away and in the same
way people who never apply to medicine
because they think they are not going to
be good enough if i could guarantee that
they could get into medical school they
would probably end up becoming excellent
doctors so i just find it very very
frustrating how many roadblocks we have
put in place of ourselves as adults to
get started with doing things and why we
are so unaccepting of being terrible at
things at the start and why we don't
respect people who actually try new
things a lot more than we do the thing
is it's not just starting a youtube
channel it is the first time that people
go into surgery that they are scared of
being a beginner i know a lot of my
friends who are now becoming foundation
ear doctors and they are completely
terrified to be a beginner at this thing
or it's even people using chopsticks for
the first time they just find it super
embarrassing and scary to do it i find
it so funny that as adults we look down
on people who are beginners rather than
kind of respecting them because there is
nothing more terrifying and humbling
than being a beginner at all so
terrifying to start something that you
can't control that you don't know how
good or bad you will be at especially
when this thing is done in public all my
life i avoided this completely i only
stuck to things that i knew i was good
at which were science and school i never
actually went out of this and just to
clarify i am definitely 100 projecting
and this is coming because of how much
pressure i have felt in this thing in
general and how much kind of
internalized pressure i had towards
being a beginner but i will say right
now i have never told anyone in real
life that i have a youtube channel i
just find it so scary to say that out
loud in person because i feel as though
i am just like such a beginner at this
thing and it's really really
embarrassing to be a beginner and
sometimes i look back on my videos and i
think that was so amateur and it was so
bad and you know you completely messed
your points up and you didn't say the
thing that you had in mind and it
doesn't come across well and i think oh
this is so so
embarrassing and instead of thinking
that oh yes i am a beginner it's been
only a few months i've been doing this
thing and obviously it will improve and
therefore kind of admitting that out
loud i am the first person who will just
like keep it under wraps unless someone
already knows and then i'll say oh yeah
yeah i do and just like end the
conversation there so i think this is
one of the things that kind of spurred
my frustration but especially trying to
see other people um get started with
changing their lives or turning their
kind of careers around and seeing how
scared we are and just starting things
from the beginning that i thought what
is this why are we doing this this is so
so so brave and incredible i love ryan
holliday's three points on being a
beginner he says that when you are just
starting you can be sure of a few
fundamental realities number one you are
not as good as important as you think
you are number two you have an attitude
that needs readjusting and number three
most of the things that you have learned
in book or school is outdated and wrong
and i feel like this just shows the kind
of experience that everyone who starts
thinking from scratch has to go through
and they are being kind of worn down
already by the task of um kind of
relearning everything that they need to
do and readjusting themselves and
humbling themselves that's on top of
that just having this kind of internal
pressure which is very hard to get rid
of but adding then on top of that the
external pressure it just becomes too
much so they never end up doing things
that they can be doing or like in my
case the things that we are doing anyway
just become not as casual as they could
be and they become a lot a lot of
pressure so today i just felt like
going on this rant and kind of
emphasizing that being a beginner is
actually incredibly incredibly cool it
takes so much bravery it is such a
humbling and incredible experience and i
think we should not judge them as much
as we do i love this phrase from samuel
johnson which says when a dog walks on
his hind legs it's not how well he does
it but that he does it at all or the
watson bear quote which i quote a lot
more which is along the lines of if you
see a waltzing bear it's not how
delicately he does it but that he
walters at all and i think when we are
going outside our comfort zone
especially when we are completely
turning around and doing something that
we've never done before and are complete
amateurs we are waltzing bears we are
dogs walking on our hind legs it is
supposed to be ridiculous it's not
supposed to be incredible the incredible
part is that we did it at all so yes
actually i think there is something so
much cooler and braver when you're
putting out youtube videos to two
viewers than when you're putting them
out to two million viewers because it
takes a whole different type of strength
to do that thing in the first case so
yeah when your friends from back home or
starting tick tock channels or you know
your neighbor in his 40s start is
deciding to go into medicine or fishing
or whatever i think that should be
actually a very very very cool thing i
wish as a society we started to become a
bit less judgmental towards this and
especially i wish we were a bit less
judgmental towards ourselves when we're
doing these things but yes that is me
rant over um thank you so much for
listening if you did and i do hope that
if there's something that you have
wanted to do in the past or something
that you still want to do and you're
scared of being a beginner in just go
for it and good luck because it's
absolutely incredible but yeah thank you
so much for listening to me if you did i
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day be kind yourself and others and
don't believe everything you think
thanks bye